[Musik]
die kommen und zudem pause zum
stammtisch schön sind sie dabei mit dem
kinder haben ist dass in dieser zeit
irgendwie schwierig gerade jüngst hat
sich eine ganze reihe von
schriftstellerinnen ihrem frust von der
seele geschrieben was sie dauernd
gefragt werden warum sie eigentlich
keine kinder haben
als wäre es irgendwie egoistisch sich
gegen kinder zu entscheiden
gleichzeitig wird plötzlich darüber
diskutiert ob es falsch ist überhaupt
kinder zu bekommen denn kinder seien
schlecht fürs klima und außerdem sowieso
ein ego projekt der eltern ja wie ist
das nun eigentlich mit den kinder haben
[Musik]
welch ein jubel welcher begeisterung
welcher anteilnahme wegen eines babys
der sohn von prinz harry und mägen der
herzogin von sussex geboren am 6
der kleine wird wohl nie könig trotzdem
kennt die halbe welt seinen namen und
freut sich über seine geburt sollte sie
wirklich ein selbstverwirklichung
projekt von harry und megan sein
seine geburt eine falsche entscheidung
die vorstellung scheint absurd seinen
namen kennen nur wenige raphael samuel
es 27 jahre alt und lebt in mumbai er
hat seine eltern verklagt weil sie ihn
ohne sein einverständnis in die welt
gesetzt haben
die klage ist ernst gemeint auch wenn er
stets mit angeklebtem bart auftritt er
will anonym bleiben
samuel ist anti natal ist er glaubt dass
am leben zu sein unterm strich
schlechter ist als nicht geboren zu
werden
er stellt sich damit in die tradition
von arthur schopenhauer wo da im koran
und david banner da mit der klimakrise
hatte an tina tourismus nun neuen
aufwind erhalten kinder zu bekommen sei
aus ökologischen gründen fragwürdig
behaupten klimaaktivisten der club of
rome brachte die idee ein jeder frau
eine prämie von 80000 franken zu
bezahlen wenn sie bis 50 maximal ein
kind geboren hat und die bewegung wollen
cherry jungen extinction moment beruf
sogar dazu auf freiwillig auszusterben
sind paare die kinder bekommen
tatsächlich klimasünder muss sich in
zukunft nicht rechtfertigen wer keine
kinder hat sondern wer kinder bekommt
oder ist das kinderkriegen nicht doch
viel eher privatsache und geht niemanden
etwas an kinder zu kriegen eine
privatsache ich freue mich sehr dass
jetzt zu diskutieren mit meinen gästen
am stammtisch ich begrüße ganz herzlich
bei uns die ersten meyers ist
professorin für philosophie an der
humboldt universität zu berlin und unter
anderem eine expertin für fragen der
klinik und ich begrüße bei uns cars we
knew max ist philosophin und
kulturjournalistin ebenfalls aus berlin
und hat sich immer wieder mit fragen
auseinandergesetzt zu tun haben mit
philosophie und mutterschaft und bei uns
zu gast ist auch stefan renner ist
philosoph am ethik zentrum der
universität zürich untersteht der
bewegung des so genannten effektiven
tourismus sei eine bewegung die sagt wir
sollten die bestmögliche welt herstellen
und zwar auch für die zukünftigen
generationen ganz herzlich willkommen
hier stammtisch
'wir sind kinder denn nun eine
privatsache oder nicht also zunächst mal
kann ich das durchaus nachvollziehen
dass man wenn man selbst überlegt ob man
kinder bekommen möchte ökologische
gründe genauso wie viele andere gründe
in seine überlegungen mit einbeziehen
ich denke aber dass man sich moralisch
keinen vorwurf machen kann gegenseitig
dafür wie die entscheidung ausfällt und
zwar in die eine oder andere richtung
nicht also wieder diejenigen die sich
dagegen entscheiden kinder zu bekommen
noch diejenigen die sich dafür
entscheiden sollten dafür moralische
vorwürfe kassieren und das scheint mir
die gegenwärtigen diskussionen durchaus
der fall zu sein und insofern würde ich
insofern dann sagen tatsächlich ist das
privatsache also die ausschlaggebenden
gründe entweder kinder zu bekommen oder
keine kinder zu bekommen das sind
tatsächlich ganz individuelle gründe die
damit zu tun haben wie man sich sein
leben vorstellt also könnte man auch
sagen ob ich kein kind habe oder sieben
kinder habe das geht erstmals keinen
etwas an außer mich und was mein partner
ganz genau so würde ich das jetzt erst
mal durchaus steht er rede nur sie
nicken aber sind ja trotzdem eigentlich
so ein bisschen skeptisch wir uns unter
dem widersprechen wollen also ich glaube
wie viele kinder wir heute haben das
durchaus etwas wofür wir verantwortung
übernehmen sollten und verantwortung
würde ich ganz wörtlich verstehen wir
sollten antwort geben können und geben
wenn jemand uns nach unseren gründen
dafür fragt müssen nicht für alle
handlungen verantwortung übernehmen also
zum beispiel wenn ich gerne abends vor
dem schlafengehen schlechte
kriminalromane lese und jemand mich zur
rede stellte mich fragt was meine gründe
dafür sind dann darf ich sagen das geht
sie schlicht nicht an ich muss die
person keine antwort geben das ist
privatsache aber mit dem kinderkriegen
scheint es mir nicht so zu sein also
kinder tragen bei zum klimawandel und
der klimawandel verursacht die ruine
slide zb scheint die lebensgrundlage der
in wie zum beispiel förmlich unter ihren
füßen weg zu schmelzen wenn also eine in
ried frau mich zur rede stellt mich
fragt nach meinen gründen für meine fünf
kinder dann kann ich nicht sagen das
lied sie nicht an das betrifft diese
person sehr wohl und ich sollte in der
lage sein glaube ich eine antwort zu
geben
jetzt haben sie vorhin gesagt wenn sie
jemand zur rede stellen würde warum sie
schlechte kriminalromane liest dann
denkt man ja sofort na ja es hat mich
überhaupt niemand zur rede zu stellen
also egal was ich lese aber man dürfte
sich also gegenseitig zur rede stellen
bezüglich der anzag in die man hat ich
würde sagen wir dürfen uns nach unseren
gründen fragen wenn wir sollten
versuchen wenn wir uns dafür entscheiden
kinder zu haben oder fünf kinder zu
haben das mit guten gründen zu tun und
gerade weil diese entscheidung eben auch
andere personen betrifft darf man
grundsätzlich andere auch danach fragen
interessant ist ja von numark dass das
kinder haben kinder kriegen eigentlich
eine der intimsten entscheidungen ist
die wie im leben fällen gleichzeitig
auch eine der folgenreichsten für unser
persönliches leben und trotzdem auch
politisch so aufgeladen ist also man
spricht von karrierefrauen die sich
gegen kinder entscheiden und
gleichzeitig klimasünder wie viele
kinder hat ist doch eigentlich erst mal
erstaunlich weil sie eine intime frage
ist ja es ist aber eine dieser fragen
ebenso interessanter weise an dieser
schnittstelle von intimen und
politischen liegt also eben anders als
das kriminalromane lesen ist kinder
kriegen vielleicht auch ähnlich wie so
genderfragen und religionsfragen diese
fragen sind wir als sehr intim und
persönlich empfinden die aber ganz große
politische gesellschaftspolitische
implikationen haben und wo wir natürlich
auch nicht nur persönlich entscheiden
also man muss auch sagen diese frage
nach dem kinderkriegen ist immer in
einem gesellschaftlichen kontext in dem
kinderkriegen mehr oder weniger normal
ist indem es die umgebung mehr oder
weniger vermittelt ist es okay kinder zu
bekommen oder keine kinder zu bekommen
und da gibt es ja ganz klar auch
unterschiede also man kennt das das wo
gibt gesellschaft in frankreich oder die
usa das ist abzusehen aber normalfall
man bekommt halt kinder und das ist
komisch wenn man keiner bekommt das
gesellschaften wie zb deutschland wo ich
ja mittlerweile lebe wo es sehr normales
keine kinder zu bekommen da gibt es
immer
20 prozent also ein fünftel der
bevölkerung die keine kinder hat und von
dem her ist es auch nicht weiter
auffällig man keine hat also es wird
zwar darüber diskutiert wird das macht
natürlich eine andere art von
normalzustand
aber die frage ist doch warum ich
sicherlich politikern eher die frage ist
auf welcher ebene also wir reden uns
gerne dreimal während gefühl es ist ja
nicht nur frage ich nach gründen den
anderen sondern auch fühle ich mich
bemüht ich mich zu rechtfertigen und
sehr vieles an diesen debatten auch an
diesen ethischen anfragen sind ja
sozusagen nachgeordnete rechtfertigungen
ich glaube die allermeisten leute haben
nicht wahnsinnig klare philosophisch
durchdachte systematiken entwickelt und
bevor sie kinder bekommen haben um das
zu begründen aber im nachhinein fühlen
sie sich sozusagen angesprochen und zu
erklären warum sie ja oder nein zu
dieser frage gesagt haben und das würde
dann auch sagen sie nicht unbedingt die
gründe die dazu geführt haben dass sie
kinder bekommen oder nicht bekommen
haben herangeführt werden versuchen wir
doch mal zu verstehen was jemand sagt
geglaubt wir sollten keine kinder mehr
haben und das ist verena braunschweiger
sie habt ein pamphlet kann man sagen
geschrieben sie nennt es ein manifest
kinder freistaat kinderlos das buch hat
für viel furore gesorgt und sie sagt
tatsächlich wir sollten aufhören kinder
zu kriegen und zwar unter anderem aus
ökologischen gründen wenn ich mich als
radio möchte ich moderierten oder nicht
und sollte der ökologische punkt eine
rolle spielen
und man muss das bewusstsein dass wenn
ich mich für ein kind schaltern
entscheide ich mich dadurch automatisch
gegen den größtmöglichen individuellen
beitrag zum klima- und umweltschutz
das muss ich wissen und wenn mir das
egal ist und ich das trotzdem
verantworten kann von meinem gewissen
man kann ich das machen aber ich zum
beispiel kann es nicht und deswegen bin
ich auch gute frau meier sie sind ja auf
der einen seite philosophin sie finden
klimaschutz wichtig und gleichzeitig
mutter für sie geht das wasser zusammen
ja und ich denke auch dass man zunächst
mal sich fragen müsste was eigentlich
das ziel unserer bemühungen zugunsten
des klimaschutzes ist und ich denke ein
ziel müsse es sein diejenigen menschen
die heute vom klimawandel betroffen sind
vor den folgen des klimawandels zu
schützen und dann auch den klimawandel
zu verhindern weil wir künftige
generationen davor bewahren möchten aber
worum es eigentlich nicht geht
das klima vor künftigen generationen zu
bewahren
also mir scheint dass die sache
irgendwie erst mal umzudrehen wenn man
so darauf dann schauen und insofern
glaube ich auch dass man hier selbst
wenn man mit diesen zahlen operiert mit
der sie jetzt hier operiert also kinder
zu bekommen sei die größtmögliche
klimasünder dass man da ein bisschen
vorsichtiger ausfallen muss und da
können wir vielleicht auch noch mal ein
bisschen soziale einzige teil gehen
nehmen wir doch gleich noch eine zahl
58,6 das ist wahrscheinlich die meist
genannte zahl in diesem kontext 58,6
tonnen co2 kann gemäss zahlreichen
berechnungen einsparen wer auf ein kind
verzichtet dieses kind nicht kriegt 58,6
nur kurz zum vergleich wenn sie kein
fleisch essen ein jahr lang sind es 0,8
tonnen die sie ansparen können verzicht
auf ein eigenes auto 24 tonnen
diese studien wurden natürlich auch
kritisiert aber erstmal was haben sie
von dieser zahl reden
also ich glaube die ganz ganz konkrete
zahlen muss man tatsächlich mit vorsicht
genießen es ist extrem schwierig dem
eine ziffer bei zu schreiben
zum beispiel nur so ein schwierig zu
berechnen wie viel ist der gesamte co2
ausstoß einer person
diese studie hat auch darauf beruht dass
nicht nur der co2 ausstoß meines kindes
mir zugeschrieben wird sondern auch der
kinder meiner kinder und deren kinder
wiederum und so weiter und da stellt
sich stellen sich eine reihe von
empirischen und philosophischen fragen
erstens wie viele kinder werden meine
kinder haben und zweitens wie viele co2
emissionen werden da muss man in die
zukunft schauen wie werden sich unsere
co2 emissionen fortentwickeln stellt
sich auch die philosophische frage
inwieweit oder inwiefern kann man das
überhaupt mir zu schreiben
die studie hat die co2 emissionen meiner
kinder mir zu 50 prozent zugeschrieben
die co2 emissionen meiner enkel mehr zu
25 prozent zugeschrieben usw
und auch darüber könnte man diskutieren
also die zahl ist heikel aber
grundsätzlich ist es glaube ich nicht zu
leugnen
zusätzlicher mensch wird co2 emissionen
produzieren ist leistet mir unmittelbar
ein aber ich glaube tatsächlich auch was
von meier sagt das ist ja die frage ist
für wen man das klima halten sollten im
verregneten gibt es ja
der planet des indifferent uns gegenüber
es ist für uns also wir müssen unser
habitat quasi als spezies erhalten das
wäre sozial der wohnstätte des
klimaschutzes und da wäre ja auch bei
solchen zahlen halt das problem wenn man
dann denkt also weil sie so in variant
sind also ich meine die ganze bemühung
müsste doch dahingehend dass wir
generationen kreieren die weniger co2
ausstoß haben also ganz genau und das
gibt noch einen punkt an diesen zahlen
den man vielleicht auch noch nennen
müsste also die zahlen sind so
entstanden in dem man also die pro kopf
emissionen konstant gehalten hat also
man geht davon aus letzlich dafür 50
jahren noch genauso viel emittiert wird
wie heute und den 100 und 150 und man
hat das dann jeweils nur durch die
hälfte geteilt und durch ein viertel
durch einen 8 und bei den bei den ur
enkelkindern und dahin müssen doch denke
ich unsere bemühungen auch gehen das
will ich die aktien gehen seit er mir
sagen okay wir werden jetzt immer darauf
sehen dass wir besser bauen zum beispiel
dass also das heizen nicht mehr so viel
emissionen verursacht weil ist die zahl
ja dermaßen hoch dass das fazit was sie
ziehen in ihrem buch wir sollten zum
beispiel wirklich seltsame oder gar kein
fleisch mehr essen doch irgendwie im
verhältnis irgendwie bizarr anmutet wenn
sie gleichzeitig sagen könnten ihn hören
sie einfach auf sich zu vermehren
also beim fleischkonsum müssen so dass
die emissionen die das verursacht und
das ist ja auch nicht das einzige
problem beim fleischkonsum also aus wenn
ökologischer gibt es noch andere aber
die emissionen die das verursacht die
sind mir direkt denke ich zuzuschreiben
bei meinen kindern denke ich vielleicht
könnte man die emissionen die entstehen
wenn ich mit meinen kleinen kindern ins
flugzeug steigen auch mir zu schreiben
schon bei den erwachsenen kindern finde
ich es nicht mehr so klar bei den
enkelkindern und ur enkelkindern auch
nicht insofern haben wir da schon mal
denke ich auch eine differenz zu diesem
fleischkonsum beispiel und ich denke
wenn es darum geht sozusagen eine
politik zu machen die dafür sorgt dass
unsere enkelkinder noch gut leben können
dann müssen wir versuchen dafür zu
sorgen die bedingungen so zu verändern
dass diese lebensweise die im moment
noch so viele emissionen verursacht zu
einer wirtin der
sie weniger emissionen verursacht und
das ist letztlich sozusagen das erbe was
wir unseren enkelkindern hinterlassen
müssen dass das eine schließt das andere
nicht aus also wie viel co2 die gesamte
menschheit imitiert hängt einerseits
natürlich von unserem lebensstil ab aber
andererseits eben auch ganz klar von der
anzahl menschen die es gibt und also
glaube ich auch es schließt sich nicht
aus wir müssen natürlich versuchen auch
in anderer hinsicht unser co2 emissionen
überhaupt treibhausgasemissionen oder
klimaschädlicher handlungen zu
minimieren aber damit ist noch nicht
gesagt dass wir überhaupt nicht
diskutieren müssen über das problem
überbevölkerung ich glaube man ein
anderer punkt oder also das eine ist
klima war und man kommt noch die
überbevölkerung und kann man sich nicht
trennen und trotzdem sind es vielleicht
noch mal so ein bisschen zwei
unterschiedliche punkte
was ich aber nur kurz die zahl
nachgesehen gemäss uno wird bis mitte
jahrhundert wird die weltbevölkerung
zehn milliarden betragen
nun kann man natürlich sagen es gibt
auch schon so viele menschen es gibt
auch viele kinder zum beispiel die
waisenkinder sind wenn menschen
unbedingt kinder haben wollen könnte man
ja sagen könnten sie vielleicht auch ein
kind adoptieren
ja ja natürlich also ich meine die
natürlich ist sozusagen dieser
kinderwunsch es ist die frage ist ja wo
an welcher stelle positioniert man sich
ich meine macht man sozusagen einen
gemäßigten anti naturalismus dass man
sagt man sollte weniger kinder bekommen
oder gerne auch sich um kinder kümmern
die schon vorhanden sind oder hat man
diese ganz harte variante und sagt ziel
ist dass wir uns alle nicht mehr
reproduzieren und als spezies aussterben
weil wir als spezies nicht besonders
erfreulich sind beiden positionen kann
man ja was abgewinnen wir sind objektiv
als spezies nicht sehr erfreulich
andererseits sie können wir ethik auch
nur mit bezug auf diese spezies machen
also wie gesagt dem planeten ist es ein
bisschen egal wir werden eher
vorbeigehen der planet wird vorbeigehen
irgendwann trudeln wir in die sonne
hinein das ist voraus zwar sehr viele
die hier gerade sehr erfreulich
ich meine die ethik die machen wir ja
für uns quasi wir müssen die annahme
irgendwie haben dass es menschen gibt
sonst können wir keine ethik machen also
darum ist eine harte anti
nationalistische position irgendwie auch
absurd aber ich also ich würde gerade
sagen kann wenn wir denken der mensch
ist etwas wunderbares und die menschheit
sollte fortbestehen was meine tiefe
überzeugung ist dann haben wir gute
gründe uns mittelfristig oder
kurzfristig zu überlegen wie viele
menschen wollen wir sein vielleicht ist
gerade jetzt in kritischer punkt in die
jetzt zu viele menschen werden erhöhen
wie das risiko dass wir längerfristig
den planeten unbeliebt machen um
vielleicht aussterbenden spezies also
ich würde sogar sagen gerade aus liebe
zur menschheit müssen die mama tage im
bevölkerungswachstum das findet er gar
nicht in den industrieländern stadt und
die industrieländer sind aber diejenigen
die die probleme verursachen mit denen
wir uns im moment beschäftigen müssen
und insofern ist es so dass in
denjenigen ländern wo die
fertilitätsrate also die anzahl der
kinder pro frau sehr hoch ist das sind
die allerärmsten länder und das sind die
länder deren co2 ausstoß teilweise um
ein zehntel oder sogar hundertstel unter
unserem co2 ausstoß liegt und insofern
habe ich die befürchtung dass bei dieser
rede davon dass die überbevölkerung das
problem ist man sozusagen den blick in
die ganz falsche richtung lenkt und
überbevölkert sind in gewisser weise man
die anderen
das problem liegt aber bei uns wir
verursachen ist im moment unsere
bevölkerung wächst hat das ist
interessant weil menschen die trainer
braunschweiger und leute philosophen die
diese these vertreten die würden ja
genau auch sagen ihr könnt es nicht
hingehen und sagen ihr da im süden
sollte man weniger kinder haben weil ihr
seids sowieso schon zu viele sondern im
gegenteil wir wären diejenigen die sich
mäßigen müssen weil bei uns ein kind so
viel co2 ausstoßen wird dabei uns heizt
man bei uns kauft man binden bei uns hat
man tausende von kleidern
wir fahren in urlaub und so weiter ja
also das finde ich dann auch sagen die
bessere perspektive also da finde ich es
richtig dass sie den blick schon auf uns
richtet ich finde trotzdem der sache
nach die die anforderung deshalb auf
kinder zu verzichten und das klingt so
ein bisschen ja bei ihr so finde ich
nicht gerechtfertigt also
einerseits habe ich schon gesagt dass
man sich fragen kann inwiefern wir
überhaupt verantwortlich sind für die
emission unserer urenkel und dann denke
ich ist es auch so dass für viele
menschen jedenfalls doch kinder zu haben
und selber sei das interesse ist ich
will nicht sagen dass das für alle
menschen so ist das wirklich genauso
falsch aber vom für viele menschen ist
es ein sehr brutales interessen und das
ist alles dicht beisammen interesse ist
irgendwas allen trainings nein das würde
ich würde ich dezidiert nicht sagen
wollen
ich glaube dass es auch problematisch
das zu sagen weil frau braunschweiger
schon recht damit hat dass es für
diejenigen die keine kinder haben
möchten auch belastend ist immer wieder
damit konfrontiert zu werden dass das
irgendwie unnatürlich sei und die rede
davon dass das ein natürlicher trieb sei
die suggerierte also das möchte ich ganz
bestimmt nicht aber diejenigen die gerne
kinder hätten für die es das etwas was
für sie in ihrem leben wichtig ist und
anders als ganz viele andere dinge also
zum beispiel das bedürfnis zu verreisen
oder das bedürfnis sich gesund zu
ernähren ist das nicht ersetzbar also
wenn man das bedürfnis hat so verreisen
muss man es nicht mit dem flugzeug tun
wenn man das bedürfnis hat sich gesund
zu ernähren und muss man dafür kein
fleisch essen
aber wenn man das bedürfnis hat ein kind
zu bekommen was soll man tun ja da gibt
es sozusagen wenig was da an
kompensation möglich ist zum beispiel
stellt also ich möchte auch überhaupt
nicht sage nichts mehr falsch überhaupt
ein kind zu haben
das glaube ich gar nicht glaube wir
können absolut verantworten auch hier
kinder zu haben habe stellt sich die
frage zum beispiel wie viele und und ist
es ein banales interesse zum beispiel
dass man vier kinder braucht oder fünf
kinder braucht da finde ich kann man
durchaus nachfragen und sagen vielleicht
sollte unser ideal werden eine art
kleinfamilie wo wir vielleicht zwei
kinder das gilt ja auch es gibt die
sogenannte small family fx also
philosophen und philosoph ihnen die
dafür plädieren zu sagen ein bis zwei
kinder im industrialisierten ländern
sollten reichen
das sind wir natürlich schon sehr nahe
jetzt bei der ein kind politik in china
wieder her wir sind ja aber auch
faktisch sehr nahe dran also alle
westeuropäischen länder haben ja eine
geburtenrate von unter zwei kindern
durchschnitt pro frau der punkt ist doch
glaube ich der dass das in gewisser
weise auch zwei diskussionen sind dieses
wozu denn aneinander vorbeilaufen das
eine sind diese ethische vom individuum
ausgehende frage kann ich es
verantworten noch einen menschen die
welt zu setzen weil die welt ist
irgendwie geht den bach hat mit dem
klimawandel und dann macht es noch
schlimmer mit diesem neuen menschen und
die andere ist ja diese politische
diskussion die wir in den westlichen
industrienationen neben überwiegenden
teil haben dass wir eben natürlich
bevölkerungspolitik betreiben und zwar
eine pro naturalistische
bevölkerungspolitik also das heißt dass
bruno senna sind dass man sozusagen das
bedürfnis hat dass es mehr kinder geht
oder dass man politische stellschrauben
zu stellen sucht wo man in dem gesamten
wandel der eben in den letzten 50 jahren
auch extrem war was die
geschlechterverhältnisse was die
überhaupt tätigkeit von frauen betrifft
innen und außerhalb des hauses dass man
dem soweit begegnet dass man es
attraktiver macht manchmal auch ganz
selektiv attraktiver für akademikerinnen
kinder zu bekommen und dann merkt man
bevölkerungspolitik ist überhaupt nicht
harmlos und das eine problem ist diese
nord-süd-gefälle also die sollen kleine
kinder kriegen in der
bevölkerungspolitik dass immer jemand
anderes der lieber keine kinder bekommen
sollte und es ist aber auch immer eine
spezifische gruppe die kinder bekommen
sollten nämlich die gut gebildeten
deutschen frauen die müssen jetzt
mittels kitas und so weiter dazu
gebracht werden dass sie mehr kinder
bekommen also dieser dieser stand ist ja
jeden der politische stand den wir haben
und man kann sich doch gesamt
gesellschaftspolitisch fragen sind die
europäischen staaten die überwiegend in
frankreich erfolgreich in deutschland
weniger erfolgreich in der schweiz ist
in der mitte eigentlich versuchen die
geburtenrate zu fördern
ob die mit dieser politik noch auf der
richtigen spur liegen also die
geburtenrate fördern kann man
tatsächlich aus anderen gründen auch in
frage stellen das ist das würde ich
schon auch denkt nur die mittel mit
denen die geburtenrate vielleicht
gefördert wird sind der zugleich oft
auch mittel mit denen zum beispiel die
verbindung von erwerbsarbeit und
familienleben gefördert wird und wenn
man sich sozusagen darauf konzentrieren
würde das in den vordergrund zu rücken
und nicht zu sagen wir fördern hier die
geburtenrate
sondern wir fördern die vereinbarkeit
von erwerbsarbeit und familien
dann würde ich denken ist es nach wie
vor eine gute sache und dann würde ich
auch nicht sagen man sollte diese maß
waren mal lieber lassen zugunsten des
klimas kommen ein bisschen auf ein
anderes thema ich würde gerne noch
einmal zurück auch zu dieser frage sie
haben gesagt wir müssen uns ja mal
überlegen urlaub machen kann man ja auch
anders nun gibt natürlich menschen die
zum beispiel keine kinder haben und die
sagen moment mal ich bin auf jene
personen die reist eben mal gern wieso
habt ihr leute mit kindern eigentlich
das gefühl ihr könnt mir meine reisen
verbieten und madig machen
währenddessen ihr euch davor pflanzen
ihr wollt also ich würde das gerne noch
besser verstehen sie haben ja gesagt was
alles interesse also das wollen wir
nicht haben weil das schließt diejenigen
aus die keine kinder haben wollen aber
was ist das denn genau dieser wunsch
nach einem eigenen kind auch ein wunsch
der sich offenbar nicht kompensieren
lässt damit andere kinder zu adoptieren
was sie eine möglichkeit wäre ich glaube
da muss man auch ein bisschen vorsichtig
mit sein weil die anzahl der
adoptionswilligen eltern also derjenigen
die gerne kinder adoptieren möchten in
den industrieländern nach nach meinem
wissen oft auch einfach zu sagen über
dem liegt was da möglich ist insofern
glaube ich kann man das jetzt auch nicht
einfach sagen
dadurch lösen dass man leuten sagt dann
adoptiert doch lieber ein kind scheint
mir aber vielleicht bin ich da auch
nicht hinreichend informiert aber ich
denke dass es grundsätzlich ein
interesse ist was so banal ist dass man
es weniger gut als andere dinge ersetzen
können und ich denke dass wir zum
beispiel deutlich denn wenn mir jetzt
jemand sagen würde die kleinen kinder
mit dem flugzeug
das geht auch mit auf dein konto dann
wäre ich auch bereit zu sagen ja das
kommt auch mein konto aber was das
resultat dieser überlegung da würde ich
doch lieber aufs fliegen verzichten als
auf kinder und insofern scheint mir zu
sagen
in vielen fällen
eigentlich die entscheidung er in diese
richtung zu gehen
aber darf ich noch mal fragen warum sie
denken so zu sagen dass uns das
überhaupt nicht zuzurechnen ist also
haben wohin gesagt die emissionen der
enkel werden sozusagen für die kann ich
nicht mehr verantwortlich gemacht werden
das sehe ich jedoch nicht habe doch
heute die entscheidungen kind zu haben
oder nicht und ich weiß wenn ich das
habe dann wird dieses kind und seine
enkel und enkelkinder co2 emissionen
produzieren warum sollte ich sozusagen
von vornherein da aus der verantwortung
sein also einmal denke ich dass es
durchaus bereiche gibt von denen wir
jetzt schon sagen würden
für die sind wir nicht verantwortlich
wenn unsere erwachsenen kinder
wenn meine erwachsene tochter sich
irgendwie was moralisch zu schulden
kommen lässt
dann bin ich dafür vielleicht nicht
dadurch schon verantwortlich dass ich
sie in die welt gebracht hat scheint mir
also mir scheint dass wir normalerweise
auf unsere erwachsenen kinder nicht so
gucken dass wir sagen wir haben uns
deren moralische verfehlungen
zuzurechnen andererseits wenn abzusehen
dass das unsere erwachsenen kinder gar
nicht anders können als so viel zu
emittieren so viel co2 auszustoßen wie
wir weil wir ihnen sozusagen ein system
hinterlassen haben indem ihr bedürfnis
nach mobilität nach wie vor nur so
befriedigt werden kann indem sie nach
wie vor nun mit dem auto zur arbeit
fahren können in dem nach wie vor der
bereich sozusagen von fossilen
energieträger lebt dann würde ich denken
haben wir uns dazu zu schreiben aber ich
würde denken das ist genau die
stellschraube an der wir drehen sollten
wir sollten versuchen unseren kindern
die möglichkeit zu geben und damit
selbst schon anzufangen nicht diesen
hohen co2 verbrauch weiter zu haben
ich würde vorschlagen ich frage mal kurz
was das publikum so denkt weil es
interessiert mich auch ob sie zum
beispiel der meinung sind diese ganze
rechnerei die die davor geführt haben
leuchtet ihnen das ein und warfen das
absurd ich finde das ein bisschen schade
dass wir heutzutage nur noch die kinder
auf zahlen jetzt reduzieren dass mein
kind das seit 153 kommen neun tonnen
oder weiß ich nicht was wussten dass der
die moral ist das kind nicht ein
emotional eine emotionale angelegenheit
oder ist es nur eine zahl das ist finde
ich ein bisschen schade dass und das ist
so reduziert sich die kritik nehme ich
gleich nachher mit an den tisch darf ich
sie fragen finden sie kinder zu haben
ist ein eu-projekt ich denke ja ich
denke schlussendlich ist es wichtig dass
es eine bewusste entscheidung ist ob man
jetzt ein kind haben wird oder nicht und
wenn es eine bewusste entscheidung ist
dann ist es sich auch für sich selber
und somit einige projekte und ist es
damit für sie auch negativ gefärbt oder
sich rein so destruktiv das ist dann ein
eu projekt weil man selber entschieden
habt wenn es eine bewusste entscheidung
ist und ein bewusstes was es mit sich
bringt ein krieg ist es nicht unbedingt
verwerflich ich frage mal weiter
vielleicht gibt's ja jemanden sind sie
zum beispiel der meinung man müsste das
kinder haben rechtfertigen
eigentlich nicht nein also ich finde
kinder haben was wunderbares ich finde
es schade dass wir ja schon gesagt hat
dass wir es auf zahlen reduzieren
es ist ja im endeffekt immer ein
eu-projekt wenn ich mich entscheide kein
kind zu haben es ist auch mein projekt
sozusagen ein kinder freies leben zu
führen
ich glaube diese frage
man muss tiefer fragen als inwiefern ist
es ethisch verantwortbar ob ich so und
so viel co2 mit meinem kind produzieren
dann fragen sie mal liefern kann ich für
das kind sorgen zum beispiel also
natürlich auch finanziell aber bin ich
auch als mensch in meiner persönlichkeit
genug reifer mann kind ankick kind
gerecht zu werden in der erziehung und
auch als persönlichkeit so würde ich
fragen
vielen dank frage ich einfach mal weiter
finden sie kinder haben
rechtfertigungsbedarf dich heute finde
ich wichtig finde es immer nur ein sehr
intimes und emotionales thema
ich denke wenn man sich für kinder
entscheidet was man nicht darüber
nachdenken was co2 ausstoß ist sondern
vielleicht einfach in der erziehung
mitgeben dass man eben kinder daraufhin
er zieht so wenig wie möglich co2
auszustoßen das ist eher ein
erziehungsthemen wenn die davor ist
emotional und im team gibt es gar
niemand hier im raum der die der meinung
ist das ist wirklich auch eine
ökologische frage des ordens das heute
gehe ich auch in dieser art und weise
überlegen doch hier nicken leute es muss
ich mich hier irgendwie dadurch bringen
ich komme zu ihnen was es heißt auf
jeden fall eine ökologische frage aber
was ich vorhin gedacht habe ist auch
dass vor allem diese entscheidung ein
kind zu haben oder nicht die hängt
meistens hat an den frauen und die
frauen müssen sich dafür rechtfertigen
ob sie kinder haben oder nicht also
unter ob sie eine karriere machen oder
nicht aber es ist auf jeden fall eine
ökologische entscheidung weil wir für
die nächsten generationen diese
entscheidung treffen und uns hier da
einfach völlig aus dem spiel nehmen
ich komme fast nicht zu ihnen aber sie
bekommen ein baby haben sie sich das
überlegt vorher in dieser art und weise
wenn ich ehrlich bin ein aber ich denke
auch es geht darum jetzt ist das kind
was liebst du four
und was machst du das gut vielen dank
wir könnten ja auch ich sag das jetzt
mal währenddessen nicht unterwegs bin
uns überlegen greta thunberg zum
beispiel die gab es ja nicht wenn die
eltern von greta sich schon zu dieser
zeit diese gedanken gemacht hätten also
dass wenn ich das darf will ich das
unbedingt auch noch gerne betonen weil
ich jetzt meistens so geredet habe von
den co2 emissionen unserer kinder dass
man muss sie auf jeden fall sagen dass
kinder noch andere dinge hinterlassen
als co2 und dass sie auch sehr sehr
viele
positive auswirkungen haben also zum
beispiel eben dass es natürlich einfach
ein wunderbares projekt sein kann für
die eltern aber kinder haben auch eine
sehr wichtige ökonomische funktion
innerhalb einer gesellschaft also den
gesellschaften zu stark altern ist es
eine große belastung für den sozialstaat
dann glaube ich auch haben neue
generationen eine enorm wichtige
kulturelle funktion also kultureller
wandel oder auch technologischer wandel
und fortschritt hat sehr oft
stattgefunden
durch neue jüngere generation zb jetzt
sind die streitenden schülerinnen und
schüler das beste beispiel scheinen die
ältere generation aufzuwecken und
schließlich glaube ich auch das ist
einfach intrinsisch wertvoll ist und
schön wenn neues leben entsteht also ich
glaube die unterm strich leben sollten
wir sicher nicht nur über klimaeffekte
von kindern sprechen und wenn man sich
das ganze anschaut ist es eine sehr
komplizierte frage habe ich glaube
einfach auch wir dürfen es nicht leugnen
dass es eben doch auch die ökologische
frage ist damit nehmen sie jetzt auch
ein bisschen die kritikpunkte auf dass
die leute im publikum gesagt haben ist
doch schade denn wir kinder jetzt nur so
aus negativen emissions- beitrag
vermessen und nicht sehen wie viel gutes
kinder in die welt bringen genau und
also rittertum becker ist jetzt ja auch
noch mal ein gutes beispiel was sie
gerade genannt hatten also dies ja
diejenigen die ihre eltern wohl auch
jedenfalls wenn man diesen berichten
glauben kann aufgerüttelt hat und dazu
gebracht wird nicht ins flugzeug zu
steigen mit ihren kindern also insofern
hat greta thonberg jedenfalls die co2
bilanz ihrer eltern reduziert und nicht
erhöht weil sie davon abgebracht hat
nach wie vor so viel zu imitieren wie
bislang und vielleicht nochmal einmal
auf diese folgen orientierten
überlegungen auf diese ja sehr stark
auch abzielen zu sprechen zu kommen also
diejenigen menschen die überhaupt dafür
vielleicht empfänglich werden dass man
sagt man kann jetzt aus ökologischen
gründen keine kinder bekommen
das wäre doch wohl diejenigen die in
deren überlegungen überhaupt das eh
schon eine ziemliche rolle spielt wenn
die nun ausgerechnet keine kinder mehr
bekommen
dann muss man sich vielleicht auch
sorgen machen darüber wie dann die
künftige generation so zusammen
ist das also noch mal sozusagen auf dem
beispiel auf das problem der erziehung
zurückzukommen haben jetzt ja auch
einige aus dem publikum gesagt dass es
wichtig ist den kindern da was mit zu
geben
auch ein ökologisches bewusstsein aber
sie fallen dann aus als eltern die das
zu ernst nehmen mit witz wenn ich würde
sagen also eine form verantwortung zu
übernehmen dafür dass man ein kind hat
ist eben diesem kind wehrte mir zu geben
unter anderem ökologische werte das wäre
eine form die verantwortung für diesen
schritt zu unternehmen
das würde ich eben genauso sind
vielleicht würde ich gerne noch bevor
wir dann einen schritt weiter gehen
einen punkt noch aufnehmen man kann ja
doch irgendwie auch ich hatte so ein
bisschen den eindruck fühlen dass die
leute in unklaren fällen verspielen
bei dem überhaupt rechnen also sie haben
was gesagt na ja also es gibt da schon
ökologische punkte die wir mit
einbeziehen müssen aber sie war
natürlich nicht nicht leugnen dass
kinder nicht auch ganz viel gutes in die
welt bringen können
das kann man erst mal sagen das ist doch
eigentlich erstaunlich wie so sollen die
überhaupt so rechnen können jetzt nicht
einfach mal sagen ja menschen kriegen
haut kinder mein gott ist doch wunderbar
also gucken wir so auf die welt
aber ich meine also auf eine gewisse
weise stimmt es doch also kinder singen
ist nun mal die art und weise wie sich
unsere spezies reproduziert also es ist
irgendwie alternativlos für uns als
spezies jetzt kann jeder individuell
irgendwie finden ich möchte ja oder nein
kinder und fast vieles in diesem diskurs
auch bei frau wunsch wieder ist ja
sozusagen das unbehagen daran dass man
bewertet wird das gut oder schlecht
gesehen wird als frau und das macht oder
nicht macht also diese art von sozusagen
mean girl bewertungen die dann noch
somit also kleine gemeinheit im alltag
geht also mit schränkt das klima
argument scheint mir tatsächlich dann
irgendwie das schwächste zu sein wenn
man kinder dann tatsächlich nur noch so
betrachtet weil natürlich als spezies
müssen wir quasi wende überleben dann
müssen es besser machen und besonders
überleben wir halt nicht das kann auch
passieren aber das wird nicht passieren
weil wir alle uns kollektiv entscheiden
keine kinder mehr zu bekommen
von dem her ist in gewisser weise diese
frage sollten wir wegen des
klimaschutzes keine kinder mehr bekommen
maximal irrelevant für den alltag
jetzt reden dass wir ihnen nicht
gefallen
warum man sie maximal irrelevant also
ich es ist schlicht er hat nie leute neu
so drüber nachdenken sind sowieso die
also ungefähr fünf menschen die ich
kenne die in der weise vergeistigt sind
dass sie sich vor dem entscheid zu
kindern solche gedanken machen und es
ist also wenn natürlich ist dass diese
kinder frage ist interessant weil sie
genau auf diese grenze steht zwischen
uns als ethischen frei entscheidenden
wesen und dem dass wir als biologisches
spezies eben kinder haben müssen sonst
gibt es uns nicht mehr
und dann gibts auch niemand mehr über
nacht haben wir wären ja dann letztlich
auch wer sagen die schade denn es uns
nicht mehr geben würde und serien da
sind ja durchaus der meinung es gibt
auch sehr viele gründungs fortzupflanzen
weil wir sollten nicht aussterben warum
also so schade fand ist es jetzt nicht
also ich meine doch also wir sind
sowieso episode
also wir werden einen anderen naja aber
wir sind wir haben es vielleicht bis zu
einem gewissen grad mindestens in der
hand wie lange dieser episode dauert und
ich glaube wir sollten versuchen
möglichst alles daran zu setzen dass sie
möglichst lange dauert weil lassen weil
mir scheint es eine wunderbare sache
wenn es auf der welt zufriedene menschen
gibt die mutes leben leben können und
insofern würde ich klar denken wir aus
diesem grund auch müssen wir jetzt
vorsichtig sein aber wenn sie so
überlegen und ja in dieses rechnen
machen wir dann nicht hinten raus kommen
wir müssen kinder haben vielleicht nicht
sieben aber 1,8
weil wenn dann keiner mehr reiche hat
dann gibt es uns nicht mehr und was
würden sie ja problematisch finden also
ich glaube auf jeden fall es gibt auch
gute gründe kinder zu haben und zum
beispiel einen grund scheint mir zu sein
dass man eben einer person ein leben
schenken kann und es scheint mir
zunächst einmal doch irgendwie auch ein
eu projekt also schenken ist mein ego
projekt schenken scheint mir nicht immer
ein eu projekt zu sagen er kann dir nur
ganz kurz noch was ist der unterschied
zwischen es gibt gute gründe kinder zu
haben und die wir müssen kinder haben
kann mir das mal ein bisschen also bei
der frage habe ich eine pflicht eine
handlung zu tun ist immer auch relevant
wie viel würde es mich kosten dieser
zu tun also wenn ich an einem teich
vorbei gehe und ertrinken mensch wenn es
mich gar nichts kostet dieser person das
leben zu retten dann habe ich wohl die
moralische pflicht dar einzuspringen und
diese person zu retten
wenn ich mein leben riskiere ist gehen
würde wenn ich die person rettet dann
habe ich keine pflicht ich habe immer
noch gründe das zu tun aber man kann ich
mir keinen vorwurf machen wenn es nicht
hören genauso würde ich sicher auch
sagen mit kindern aus ich glaube wir
haben auch gründe kinder zu kriegen aber
sicher nicht eine pflicht weil sie uns
auch extrem viel kostet wenn wir das
nicht tun wollen
ich glaube dass letztlich die frage
warum ist die menschheit weitergeben
soll gar nicht so motiv begründet werden
kann sondern ich glaube dazu kann man
einfach nur das sagen was sie dazu auch
sagen weil es eine so großartige sache
ist und punkt ich finde es aber auch
legitim an an irgendeiner stelle kommen
diese art von von begründungen einfach
an ihr ende
aber ich finde man kann schon versuchen
da konsistent zu sein sozusagen in
seiner argumentation für den klimaschutz
und und dann würde ich denken
es scheint doch letztlich so zu sein
dass wir klimaschutz auch oder
vielleicht sogar vor allem um derjenigen
menschen bilden betreiben die ansonsten
haben klimawandel betroffen wenn ich
will dass die empfindungsfähigkeit tiere
nicht ausnehmen aber der planet als
solcher scheint jetzt hier nicht sagen
das leitmotiv zu sein
machen wir den sprung zu den menschen
die da geboren werden weil jetzt mehrere
male die meinung war es ja ohnehin klar
es ist wunderbar es zur welt zu kommen
und am leben zu sein und deswegen gibt
es auch gute gründe kinder in die welt
zu setzen
die haben am anfang dieses beispiel
gesehen des inders raffl samuel der ja
seine eltern verklagt hat dass sie ihn
zur welt gebracht haben
es gibt auch das beispiel von david
bennett auch er kam bereits vor ein
südafrikanischer philosoph der seit
vielen jahren diesen sogenannten anti
natalies muss predigt also die meinung
dass am leben zu sein eigentlich keine
gute sache ist unterm strich sie lachen
also und deswegen sei es natürlich
falsch kinder zu kriegen und zwar nicht
weil es ökologischen problem ist sondern
für die einzelnen menschen schlicht
keinen kein recht und keinen grund
menschen in die welt zu bringen
ich lag nur weil ich die reaktion der
mutter von diesem interzum maximal
interessant sich sagt dass sie fans noch
mutig von ihm weil er ja weiß dass sie
beide anwälte sind das erste klagt und
irgendwie ich mir natürlich hat das
einfach eine hohe komik und also logisch
geht es ja nicht auf also vor bevor er
da war war kein ansprechbar als
individuum was irgendwelche ethischen
recht hätte da was man hätte fragen
können
jetzt ist er da jetzt kann er sich
irgendwie so oder so mit dem leben
zurechtfinden und also ich finde diese
anti sozialistischen positionen die
sagen ja immer ganz starkes wurde es
darum dass das leid in der welt so viel
größer ist als die freude die man haben
kann und darum ist es besser nicht
geboren zu sein
aber nein nein wir wollen natürlich
nicht die leute umbringen wir wollen nur
dass keine neuen entstehen und mir
scheint dass irgendwie nie wahnsinnig
plausibel also ich finde zum beispiel
aus individuell ethischer perspektive
viel wichtiger dass jemand der
tatsächlich zu viel leider fährt und
nicht leben will die möglichkeit hat
sein leben selber zu beenden wenn er das
selber wünscht also so etwas ich sterbe
ich finde ich weitaus wichtiger als die
vorstellung dass wir jetzt allen
menschen vorweg diese entscheidung
abnehmen
ob sie jetzt leben wollen oder nicht
also dem also man diesen anti metall ist
zwischen argumenten kriegt man manchmal
den eindruck als wäre die qualität eines
lebens einfach die summe seiner
glücklichen momente und auch das scheint
mir sehr sehr fragwürdig also ein leben
wird auch dadurch gut dass bestimmte
narrativen strukturen in ihm
verwirklicht werden was ist den
narrativen strukturen zum beispiel ein
sinnvolles projekt also nehmen wir an
ich hätte von klein auf den traum gehabt
mal einen hohen berg zu besteigen mir
und ich habe trainiert und ich habe
mühsal und kälte und sturm überwunden
und irgendwann eines tages stand ich
oben auf diesem berg das würde ich sagen
es ist ein sinnvolles projekt aus meinem
leben eine gewisse form von bedeutung
verleihen kann
und interessanterweise bei diesem
projekt zum beispiel sind schmerzvolle
erfahrung und light sozusagen
konstitutiver bestandteil dieses projekt
also das projekt hätte keinen sinn wenn
also schnell hat irgendwie dazu genauso
wenn man mich einfach mit medicopter
diesen berg geflogen hätte dann wäre
sinnlos geworden obwohl ich das leid
hätte vermeiden können also interessant
mit diesem leid um
david baker sagte wir leiden alle unter
einer kognitiven verzerrung wir blenden
aus dass wir jeden tag ganz oft schlafen
möchten und ich dürfen hungrig sind und
nichts essen können die müssen zur
toilette wir haben nur viren wir haben
irgendwie mühselige e mails die wir
behandeln müssen
und all das wird nicht dazu wir machen
uns da was vorlegen ist eigentlich
furchtbar findet er
also ich finde nicht grundsätzlich dass
philosophen dass ich nicht auch ab und
an mal anmaßen können anderen eine
kognitive verzerrung zu unterstellen das
gehört in gewisser weise zum job würde
ich sagen muss man halt sagt überlegt
doch noch mal es gibt auch gute gründe
die sache anders zu sehen
wenn man aber der ganzen menschheit eine
kognitive verzerrung unterstellt dann
würde ich denken müsste man sich
vielleicht selbst fragen ob sozusagen
die dieser irrtum nicht aus aus einer
art des nachdenkens resultiert gegen die
andere ganz gute gründe ein wenden
könnten und ich glaube einer dieser
irrtümer der sich bei bernard findet ist
tatsächlich diese diese kleinen episoden
von ich würde es noch nicht mal x lite
nennen also gerade durch zu haben bevor
man etwas trinkt das sozusagen alles mit
in dieser rechnung mit rein zu nehmen
das scheint mir einfach nicht plausibel
zu sein
aber was nicht zum beispiel irgendwie
schon bewegt hat ist das sich auf einer
website eines anti natta listen eine
zahl gefunden habe wie viele menschen in
deutschland antidepressiva konsumieren
und es ist erschreckend hoch ich weiß
nicht ob diese zahl stimmt oder geht es
um so was wie irgendwie 7 prozent der
bevölkerung brauchen antidepressiva oder
schlafmittel dann denkt man ja gut
vielleicht ist es mit der kognitiven
verzerren doch nicht so weit
also es gibt ein paar interessanterweise
tatsächlich relativ gut dokumentierte
kognitive verzerrung unter denen wir
tatsächlich alle zu leiden scheinen also
man kann nachweisen dass die
allermeisten menschen zum beispiel
bestimmte risiken unterschätzen also
wenn sie eine zahl angeben müssten wie
hoch die wahrscheinlichkeit alzheimer zu
kriegen oder so
schätzt man das risiko zu klein oder wir
erinnern uns sehr viel weniger lang an
schlechte dinge als ein guter dinge oder
wir halten uns alle vier relativ gut
also die allermeisten menschen denken
zum beispiel seien die besseren
autofahrer als der durchschnitts
autofahrer bestehens autofahrerin so
aber das scheint mir unterm strich auch
relativ triviale dinge zu sein die jetzt
nicht zeigen dass eigentlich unser
ganzes leben schlechte im gegenteil man
könnte auch sagen
umso netter hat uns die evolution mit
einer gewissen form von optimismus
ausgestattet und was ist mit der
argumentation die ja bei diesen bei
dieser anklage schon dem indischen
jungen mann auch vorkommt dass er sagt
ich wurde hier überhaupt nicht gefragt
und einige kinder betonen dass er
durchaus auch dass sie sagen das ist
natürlich ein öko projekte eltern nicht
nur weil sie mich nicht gefragt haben
sondern weil die meisten menschen kinder
kriegen und wenn sie gründe angeben dann
kommt sowas bei raus wie ich wünsche mir
ein gesprächspartner wenn ich alt bin
ich hätte gerne eine sinngebung ich
möchte mich gerne um etwas kümmern
dürfen
ich möchte gerne dass mich jemand
vorbehaltlos liebt man denkt man doch
irgendwie entschuldigung ist das ein
grund mich in die welt zu bringen
aber mir scheint dass erstmal
unverfänglicher grund zu sein also wenn
man zunächst mal überlegt ob man selbst
gerne kinder hätte dann scheint es
typischerweise so zu sein dass man damit
zunächst mal auf sein eigenes leben und
auf die vorstellung wie es sich dann mit
kindern gestaltet guckt und das scheint
mir erstmal ganz unproblematisch zu sein
natürlich gibt es problematische art und
weisen mit dem kind umzugehen wenn es
dann da ist also dass das kind den
eigenen lebenstraum verwirklichen soll
man hätte selber gerne einen bestimmten
beruf ergriffen das hat nicht geklappt
und jetzt soll das kind diesen beruf
ergreifen
das ist natürlich problematisch aber die
bloße tatsache dass zu dem moment wo man
sich für ein kind entscheidet man
erstmal in erster linie das eigene leben
im blick hat das schmeckt mir
unproblematisch sein und wenn es gut
läuft und ich würde sagen in aller regel
ist es so verändert sich diese
perspektive ja radikal wird der geburt
des kindes plötzlich sieht man da dieses
andere individuum und dann liegt es
einem plötzlich als individuum am herzen
und dann geht es um die interessen
dieses kindes nicht mal um die eigenen
interessen aber dieser perspektivwechsel
der findet halt erst später statt also
vor allem wenn man junge älter
sid was die alles tun damit das kind
irgendwie nachts auch gewickelt wird man
muss es stehe nun muss es rumtragen und
so weiter dann denkt man na ja also das
eu projekt ist jetzt schon ein bisschen
überstrapaziert aber vielleicht würde
ich trotzdem gerne zurück fragen frau
maja wenn ich ihn jetzt dazu habe ich
den eindruck es gibt schon kinder diego
projekte sind also man muss offenbar als
eltern doch irgendwie die richtigen
gründe haben kinder zu kriegen
ich würde nicht sagen dass man die
richtigen gründe haben muss überhaupt
kinder zu kriegen aber man muss mit den
kindern auf die richtige weise nachher
umgehen und die richtige weise mit dem
kind nachher umzugehen ist eine in der
es nicht im wesentlichen darum geht dass
es einem selbst gut geht sondern da geht
es auch darum dass es dem kind gut geht
und das kollidiert manchmal damit dass
leute in erster linie vielleicht
irgendwelche unbewältigten
zukunftsträume haben die sich jetzt zum
beispiel mit ihrem kind ausleben aber
das ist sozusagen nichts was in der
sache selbst das kinderkriegen angelegt
ist denke ich
sie warten noch darauf ergeben wenn das
stimmt was ich zu beginn gesagt habe
dass andere uns durchaus auch noch
unseren gründen fragen dürfen weil sie
es eben vielleicht auch der schlechten
krimis nicht mit den schlechten krimi es
geht es die leute nichts anhaben
vielleicht leute leiden unter dem
klimawandel und meine kinder kriegen
geht die etwas anwalt sie betrifft weil
es ihr leid unter umständen verstärken
kann dann würde sich vielleicht auch die
frage stellen ob eben gewisse gründe die
ich da als antwort liefern kann dann
problematischer sind als anderes ich
glaube zu nennen ich habe immer schon
davon geträumt ein kind zu haben das
gehört zu meiner identität es gehört zu
meiner konzeption des guten lebens ein
kind zu haben ist eine sehr sehr gute
antwort auf seine person zu sagen hören
sie einfach mein umfeld erwartet dass
ich ein kind kriege ich wollte mich dem
nicht widersetzen werde weniger gute
antwort oder vielleicht auch eine
weniger gute antwort auf die frage warum
man jetzt schon das fünfte kind in die
welt
aber ich möchte lieber hinweise auf die
umwelt ist doch ein guter hinweis geben
denn wir haben der einerseits ist diese
frage ob überhaupt kinder bekommen eine
wahnsinnig junge das muss man ja auch
mal ganz klar sagen also es gab in
früheren zeiten doch wesentlich weniger
möglichkeiten
sozusagen ein erfülltes leben zu leben
ohne kinder zu bekommen also zumindest
die hängt in gewisser weise doch an so
etwas wie verhütungsmöglichkeiten dass
man das überhaupt mit dieser intensität
fragt sollte man jetzt eine familie
herstellen oder nicht also sofern man
ein sexuell aktiver mensch ist und das
andere ist das natürlich auch diese die
frage nach dem den gründen für kinder
also den gründe geben anderen menschen
die hängt ja viel weniger wirklich an
individuell durchdachten alles an so
etwas wie einem gesellschaftlichen
kontext in dem man sich bewegt also weil
die die sache dass jetzt so sein wenn
man das sind 18 jahrhunderts romanen
liegt die kinder kommen einfach wenn man
diese romane liest und wolf land das ist
mein lieblings roman also irgendwann
wenn sie 48 es kommen keine kinder mehr
so zufällig also so aber bevor herkommen
die einfach natürlicher weil solche
roman war das mal an das von daniel
defoe also das ist einfach so die kinder
gehören natürlicherweise zudem es ablauf
dazu weil sie einfach immer so entstehen
man weiß nicht genau wie das ist wenn
kinder oder die katholischen familie
immer und bieten diese dieser dieser
natürlichkeit dass kinder einfach
entstehen die es ersetzt worden durch so
eine umgebung die es von mir erwartet
dass ich kinder einfach machen was alle
machen
das ist ja so sein der schritt den wir
gegangen sind und in dem sinne natürlich
können wir diese frage nach den gründen
fragen aber zugleich stehen wir alle
doch in sozialen kontexten drin wo wird
diese frage eben auch in gewisser weise
nicht mit dieser offenheit stellen
können weil wir unter allen möglichen
sozialen erfolg prägungen auch leben die
es natürlich oder unnatürlich für uns
erscheinen lassen kinder zu bekommen und
bei diesen vor prägungen sind wir noch
bei einem dritten punkt sozusagen aus
dessen blickwinkel man auf diese frage
schauen kann nicht die frage des
feminismus und verena braunschweiger die
glaubt ja nicht nur wir sollten keine
kinder mehr haben nach ökologischen
gründen sondern noch aus artern antina
ballistischen gründen also die gründe
dass der mensch eben leidet wenn er auf
der welt ist und drittens auch sollten
kinder frei bleiben weil alleine das
eine feministische einstellung zum
ausdruck bringt also ich muss sagen ich
bin ja radikale feministin und natürlich
kann ich dann können nutzer sein weil
für mich einfach dass gebühren der
partnerschule in kreativ ist schlecht
hin und wenn ich den erfülle dann wäre
das aus wenig mal den grauen haare
irgendwie bund werden oder es werde ich
mich komplett passieren weil er das auch
irgendwie ist und diese ganzen so von
der gesellschaft uns aufgezwängt
imperativ für die alle dazu dienen
sollen das nicht als frauen nicht nur
entfalten kann sondern mich nur noch so
massiv wie gut und irgendwelche zwänge
und jochen beuge hier eigentlich gar
nicht passen
und insofern wird es für mich in der tat
nicht zusammengehen echter feminismus
und mutterschaft sie haben zwei kinder
bezeichnen sich auf der minister geht
für sie zusammen
ja klar also ich meine der mann so zu
sein sagt es geht irgendwie unterwerfung
und ein patriarchat also natürlich leben
wir alle in der welt in der wir leben
und die also wenn man so strukturelle
begriffe leben benutzen will dann sind
wir natürlich in der situation wo wir
alle einer gesellschaftlichen systematik
die schon vorhandenes unterworfen sind
und innerhalb dieser uns dann bewegen
müssen
und natürlich ist die entscheidung
jemanden zu heiraten oder kinder zu
bekommen immer eine entscheidung die
einen verein bringt wenn man vorher noch
nicht waren wo man so noch mal ein stück
weit weiter die illusion verliert man
sein vollständig frei flottierenden
extrem autonomes ganz auf sich gestellt
das individuum das eine illusion die
mann anfang 20 manchmal haben kann wenn
man gerade von zu hause ausgezogen ist
und denke man kann alles selber
entscheiden und man es vergisst dann
eben wie sehr man doch von der umwelt
geprägt wird und wenn man dann wieder
soeben in beziehungen mit kindern ist
merkt man na ja also das war vielleicht
alles ist auch nicht ganz so selbst
entschieden
und dann muss man sich halt durch
vorstellen und natürlich hat diese
feminismus frage eine lange geschichte
also die ganzen beispiel spielt das
natürlich eine rolle
natürlich also die im feminismus ist die
frage nach der kinderlosigkeit einfach
von zentraler bedeutung deswegen weil
die kinder kinder haben über lange
jahrzehnte frauen in der spezifische
soziale volkswagen und baywa heißt es ja
ganz klar dass das muttersein nur dann
und nur in diesem einzelnen fall
wirklich berechtigt sein könnte weil so
ein ganz freie entscheidung ist aber
dass man merkt im buch an das ist ein
minimale möglichkeit das ist eine ganz
freie entscheidung sein könnte und diese
dieser topos der läuft natürlich bis
heute mit also natürlich ist man freier
ohne kinder auch als auch klar aber es
sozusagen zur freien entscheidung zu
machen
das scheint doch nach wie vor etwas zu
sein was den feminismus wichtig ist also
die reproduktive freiheit ist doch etwas
was für den feminismus heute auch noch
ein zentrales thema ist und dann würde
ich da geht das aber in beide richtungen
also keine kinder zu bekommen und kinder
zu bekommen
dass sich da irgendwie sänger einander
also wenn es um reproduktive freiheit
geht und wie beides angesprochen
schreibt mir und insofern scheint mir
auch diese debatte eine zu sein
die man nicht so ganz vorbehaltslos als
feministin so wie es sie tut sein mit
ins spiel bringen kann
insbesondere sind wir einfach daran
arbeiten dass man als frau und als
mutter nicht mehr in diese unfreiheit
getränken wird wenn man mutter wird aber
dass man jetzt deswegen als frau oder
als feminismus als feministin nicht
mutter werden sollte ich mich nicht ein
und man kann auch mutter werden und dann
aus dieser position heraus vier mutter
rächte sich einsetzen
es stimme ganz man sollte nicht in eine
position gedrängt werden aufgrund der
tatsache kind und man sollte eben
wahrscheinlich und ich glaube das ist
schon auch so also wenn ich das richtig
verstehe so eine innere motivation für
solcher man die feste von denen es ja
einige gibt es eben dass man sich
wirklich ärgert über eine gesellschaft
die einen andauernd dazu anhält kinder
zu bekommen und einem immer wieder
suggeriert man müsse das also ich selber
muss gestehen dass ich es nicht so stark
so erlebt habe aber ich kenne leute die
mir darüber auch klage führen wie sehr
ihre eltern sie immer wieder unter druck
setzen oder wie es schräg sie angeschaut
werden im freundeskreis und natürlich
wenn es diesen druck gibt und das ist ja
auch so ein dauerndes befragt werden
über diese intime enthaltung von einer
umgebung dass das als unangenehm
empfunden wird und das sozusagen die
verweigerung und die sagen nein das ist
und das auch mal öffentlich sagen und
aufschreiben auch vielleicht so eine art
von befreiungsschlag ist ich halte ja
sehr viel von ihrer these die hier
eingebracht haben dass es in der
philosophie man darum geht kognitive
verzerrung
wir kämpfen und gleichzeitig denke ich
mir ist nicht gerade das auch ein gutes
beispiel dafür dass es doch auch
schwierig ist zu sagen was heißt
eigentlich freiheit in diesem kontext
wir alle sind auch geleitet von
konventionen zb aber sind konventionen
denn immer schlecht also anders gesagt
wie finde ich einerseits heraus was
eigentlich mein wirklich freier wille
ist
uns ist es nicht auch gut gehalten zu
sein in einer gemeinschaft in der man
auf gewisse dinge so macht wie man sie
nacht
ja das ist so lange gut wie man nicht
selbst des harmony es mit dieser
gemeinschaft also in dem moment wo die
gemeinschaft von einem erwartet als frau
ein kind zu bekommen aber man möchte
kainz und das sieht man ja in gewisser
weise auch an diesem buch kann das eine
große belastung sein die dann umschlägt
vielleicht in dem fall daher dass man
dann anderen sagt warum sie etwas falsch
machen wenn sie denn nun tatsächlich
kinder bekommen und insofern würde ich
denke nein
ein mittel dagegen diese belastung zu
erzeugen ist tatsächlich diese
vorstellungen mit denen man da
konfrontiert wird selbst auch infrage zu
stellen und insofern denke ich ist es
jetzt hier tatsächlich etwas befreien
ist weil man unter keinem druck steht in
welche richtung auch immer und sagen die
tatsache dass man aber trotzdem mit
bestimmten erwartungen konfrontiert ist
die muss man sich bewusst machen und ich
glaube dadurch dass man sie sich bewusst
macht gewinnt man dann auch an freiheit
also wenn man weiß dass es diese
erwartung gibt sei es mutter zu werden
und keine zu werden
dann kann man sich dazu irgendwie
verhalten wenn man die gründe dafür oder
dagegen reflektieren kann wenn man weiß
was das mit sich bringt in unserer
gesellschaft vielleicht zum teil auch
leider noch an einbußen beruflicher art
und dann kann man sich dazu irgendwie
verhalten oder man kann maßnahmen
ergreifen die das irgendwie abfedern
und insofern ist denke ich sagen das
nachdenken darüber der schritt zur
freiheit
und das ist das was wir wir ermöglichen
sollten
unser thema am stammtisch ist das thema
kinder ein eu projekt und wir haben
nicht mehr viel zeit ich würde gerne
noch einmal versuchen so eine letzte
runde zu machen wenn sie jetzt
zurückblicken auf gespräch sind jetzt
kinder ein eu projekt ja oder nein aber
ich das gefühl sie finden alle
eigentlich kaum je
nein ich finde das projekt die grünen
oft oberflächlich sind oder auch
egoistisch und so weiter und natürlich
dann sind sie anstrengend das hat man
nicht so ganz vorausgesehen aber es
passiert und damit aber das ist auch
okay wie gesagt es geht um die nächste
generation die sich an weder ethisch
verhalten kann also das ist irgendwie
keinen grund dagegen und selbst wenn man
denken würde dass man für andere
ethische handlungen bessere gründe
braucht ich glaube in dieser frage der
darf auch in der philosophie er seine
theorie praxis lybischen das heißt das
eu projekt würde nicht heißen egoistisch
und kritikwürdig seien also insofern
gewesen sind die natürlich auch
egoistische interessen haben also ich
egoismus ist ja nicht also wenn egoismus
kritikwürdig wäre also es ist doch so
eine großtat sache des menschseins ich
würde aussagen also eben kinderkriegen
drückt sich oft gerade eine nicht
egoistische seite des menschen aus also
ich glaube viele menschen haben auch
deswegen kinder weil sie gerne
verantwortung für andere menschen
übernehmen weil sie es schön finden wenn
jemand sie braucht insofern es gratis
dann eine andere personen orientierte
haltung die sich ausdrückt in diesem
wunsch kinder zu kriegen
ja ich glaube man muss die die gesamten
konsequenzen mit einbeziehen ist eine
enorm komplizierte frage was dann damit
herauskommt aber ich würde nicht sagen
dass ist ein ego projekt von vornherein
wurde ebenfalls sagen das eu projekt im
begriff ist der in dem schon irgendwie
moralische kritik mit schwingt aber ich
würde sagen wenn man den begriff mal
davon befreit und sagt kinder sind ein
projekt das man verfolgt erst mal im
eigenen interesse
was aber umschlagen
in eine berücksichtigung der interessen
der kinder dann ist das eine sehr schöne
sache und wenn das beides zusammen geht
dann denke ich kann man auch durchaus
sagen dass es ein ego projektes aber
keins was irgendwie kritikwürdig ist
wenn ich irgendwie schon klar ist dass
dieses kind ein sehr sehr schlechtes
leben haben wird aber da würde ich sagen
ist einfach auch die anderen hat an tina
tallis tische position überzogen
normalerweise ist das einfach nicht zu
erwarten
vielen herzlichen dank für die angeregte
diskussionen frau maja harry jenner vom
herzlichen dank dass sie hier warten
[Applaus]
schlüssel wieder mit einer postkarte
wenn der klügere nachgibt geschieht
dummes eine postkarte die ich gefunden
habe
deswegen hoffe ich mal dass sie den
klügeren folgen sonst geschieht das
nächste woche spricht ich bossard mit
ranga yogeshwar über künstliche
intelligenz dann wieder im studio in
zürich ich hoffe sie sind mit dabei
vielen dank fürs interesse auch ihnen zu
hause eine gute woche
bis bald
[Applaus]
[Musik]